[音楽]
に
仕方が
朝までに
したね
車に
仕事で
[音楽]
します
私は
幸せでありますように
私の中に
苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
願い事は
叶え
られます
私に
外れない
[音楽]
ます
私は
幸せでありますよ
幸せである
私は
幸せでありますが
私は修行されますように繰り返し
存じます
[音楽]
幸せでありますように
私の私
生命の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよ
[音楽]
少し
生命の
願い事は
叶えられますよ
私の
責めにも
悟りの
光が
あれますよ
[音楽]
幸せであります
よ私の
[音楽]
幸せになります
よ私の
幸せでありますよ
生命が幸せがありますようにと繰り返し何
します
ものが
幸せでありますように
生き出してるのは
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよ
生きて
いるものの
願い事が
叶え
られますよ
に
生きて
いるものにも
里芋
光が
現れますよ
生き出してるものが
幸せであり
ます
生き出してるままが
幸せでありますよ
生きとしているものが
[音楽]
生きて
いるものが
幸せでありますが
してるものが
幸せになります
生きたしてるものが
幸せであります
ように
はいありがとうございます
はい今日はこの
謙虚という
手間をお願いされてありましたので
中国説明しました
たくさん
データがちょっと気をそのことはできませ
んでしたので
残りだと
仏教に関する
話
問題のしあなたはこの
非常に広げるべき唯一なものとして解かれ
ているのでですから
真理を語ること
信じを知らない方々に教えてあげることは
施しの中で最高なこと教えてやると
要するに
生命を助けるならば
究極の助けは
生命に
真理を理解して
あげる
理解するように
協力してあげることでございます
それは懸命今日の
説法を
我々の仏教の立場から見ればスープを回
ですけど
仏教は嫌い子にだからまあいろいろ講演会
やら色々な迷わずばってはいるんですか
まぁ今日の
説法会で
皆様に
気持ちよくすると聞いて世界的に
してこの会長費用をしてください
ます
[音楽]
です
ように
心がけになりますように3本のありますよ
と
します
テーマになります
ということはこの
英語の単語は何なのかと調べたら
有名入れて漏れして
半分という言葉
が
定義
提出的に
出ていましたので
[音楽]
私は予約する
場合いろいろ別な単語を使いますけどね
まあだいたい
決まりの単語ですからこの
意味ではありませんね結局は
これは何で文化の
非難侮辱
受けて
すごい立場が
社会が認めない
ということがそれすごい宗教的な
ありがたいことやと
語っているんですね
まぁ宗教段階っていうのは人類は昔からも
やってきたことで
これはおそらく
[音楽]
アイデアだと思いますけど
ユダヤ人のトラとかねその聖書っていうの
は結構泳いでは瞑想が
かなり非難防止を受けた
歴史になっていて
だからこそ神が仙人として
選んだという
話でこの預言者たちがね
ユダヤではね
ザラザラにたくさん出ているんですね
[音楽]
侮辱されて
非難無常上で
社外へとしては活動していないね
惨めな生活していたんですね
でも
神様が
全部この人にいろいろ教えてあげて
預言者にしているんですという宗教ですね
ですから有名に切っていうのはそちらでは
そこで
独特的なことになっていますまぁそれで
やって言うからです東京というものがね
じわじわと現れてきて
開発するためをください
人間伝説っていうキャラが出てこないん
ですね
そこで
神秘見せてから歴史点として記憶しておく
ようでも
流せるという
キャラがいたんだけどそれ人間ではなかっ
たんですね
第7
展開に一番見せたの展開に
人でそこで
魚から
すごい避難侮辱
受けて
殺されましたと
それで神様が直ちに復活してあげたぞ
ギリシャはですから
ローマ帝国に開発している
教会になりましたけども
人間だとイエスとかね
作りましたからね
[音楽]
ほとんどないんですけどまぁ
実際至ったり信じる方々に見て
そこで
この11が
裁判かけられて
住まいかけられて
棘のなんか冠をつけちゃって
避難侮辱罪だって
十字架に
イエスかこれ
言ったら
何とか矛盾する書いてありますねそれは
ユダヤ人の方という意味で調べて覚えて
ないんだけど今日は思い出せないんです
だからバカにするために書いたんですね
[音楽]
ということで
だからそこで広めれないんですね
神の子なのに
扱い
それはすごい格好いい
というかね見た子
そういうわけで私はこの
謙虚という日本語の単語ねそれは日本語の
単語ですけどね
それにこの3つの英語の単語が当てはめ
ないということ
使えますその中で真ん中に漏れ出して
派手じゃなくて
すごいなんて
言いますかね
落ち着いて
適量を教えて
両方越えないで
生活するというものすごく
英語の中では
合うんです
はいとにかくテーマに入ってみましょう
そこで
一般の方々に喧嘩では何考えているのかと
いうことはねまぁようわかってないね我々
はいろんな単語を使っていますけどね
例えば頑張るという単語もあれ何の意味
でしょうかねよう
わからんでしょう
とにかく何人ですか
そういう意味で感じですね
そういう単語結構ありますよ
あまりにも使って使って使って
意味が分かっているという感じにしている
んです
そこでみんなびっくりしますね
本当にこの言葉の意味は何ですかと
思います
だからみんなあの日本語学外国人とは
なかなかできるだけに
聞くんだからねそんなこと聞いたら分かっ
てないんだからね
[音楽]
はいそういうことでこの謙虚と単語もよく
使っている単語
単語で
我々も若い人々に
もう喧嘩になりなさいとか
幼児
聞きたいとわかったような感じで言って
いる人もわかっているような感じでどちら
もわかってないんです
だから
[音楽]
実行できなくなっているんです
それだけで私はただフレーズ並べたん
でしょうまぁ
簡単に私より簡単に読めますから
内間違いとかあったら
皆様の頭の中で流してください
いちいち夜朝一時半
程度の時間に作りましたからね
まぁ
控えめに生活すること
自分の意見を
言わないこと
だから控えめに生活することで言ったら
これ一緒だっていいわけじゃないという
ことはあるでしょう中に
自分の意見を入れないことまあ
言わない方が良い場合もあるした方がいい
場合もあるしだから謙虚って
自分の意見は言わないことでもないね考え
てみれば
物事を明確に語らないこと
トラブルはまぁそうね
なんとか言うようなね
だからそれは違いますよもう私はこれは
認めてあんた言語じゃないねという風に
言われたら
ヤバいんだからそんな
喋っても何喋ってるかさっぱりわからない
んだったらこれ謙虚ではなくても頭弱く
私の
仲間でいる人々はみんなそういう連中で何
喋ってるのだったりわからない
いかがでしょうか
[音楽]
言ったらまた
それって謙虚にはないのです
みんな権利やと思っているんだよもう
そんな
患者さんの前だからねまぁちょっと謙虚に
なると元凶ではないんです
惨めな性格惨めでした
惨めに生きること
いわゆる有名人ですね
すごくありがたく思っているんですよ日本
である時期です東京かなり段階へ行けたん
ですねあれはそういう方々はそこの誇らし
に思っているんですね
それでもって
教えが広がりましたと
なんか変ですね
惨めに誰に行きたくないんですねだから
謙虚になりこないね
あれは喧嘩の人はこれ
暗い生活でいれば
あれ謙虚ですかね
あれは何のアイディアがない
スピレーションがない
例えば会議なんかに参加したらただ
座って
半分だけであの
夜はの無くあの
袋みたいな感じで
終わっちゃうんですよ
これなんでやんそんな意見によってこれ
謙虚じゃないでしょう
結局は
あれは新しいことに
挑戦しないことまあ
設定されている人生で
常備作法しっかり守って
決まりをしっかり守って
全く波を立たないで
生きる
新しいことに挑戦し
新しいことに挑戦しちゃうと
明らかこちらからもう
嫌が飛んできますよ
あるいは
固有人間いますねどこまででも
みんなに合わせるんですね
私はこの
フレーズ
考えた時はそういう人々いるんですよ
何言っても合わせる
はいそういうことで謙虚と言ったらこう
いう性格ではなかないかなと思ったらなん
かどこかでやっぱり
派手な残るんですね
次に行ってみましょうか
であのこのタイトルはこの
プログラムが
同じタイト
ルしょぼちょこと書いちゃうと
問題あると言ってくれるんだからだから
毎年会社の基準取るためにもう
全く
互い違いたいと入れるんですよそれって
学問的でも
知識的でもないんだけどねまぁ
プログラム作るのは丸っきり頭の悪い連中
だからね
だから見つけて
いるでしょう
とにかく
前のページの書籍なんでアメリ困らない時
だった
リラックスがないことまあある人は
リーダーシップな方だからね
会長としてはこの人は選びましょうと
そういうことですかね
平社員に人生を終わらせること
自分自身がそんな余計なことをやる必要は
ない
謙虚で生活すればいいんじゃないかと言っ
て人生終わるまでいらないで
終わっちゃうんですね
競争社会で相手に
チャンスをすること
これもよくありますだから社会は競争社会
だからね
商売であろうが仕事であろう教育であろう
か
政治であろうかもう何から何もで一応
競争ですね
それで謙虚な人はどうするどうぞと
今は
余計なことを思い出したんだけども
エレベーターに乗る時も結構そういう謙虚
なアホがいてものすごく気持ち悪くなるん
です
時々この
全く私が知らないことにしない公の動画で
みんな悩んでいるなら私も
後ろで並んでいる
別に
それでみんな見て
ドア開けたらはいどうぞどうぞ」って呼ん
でそれで私はみんなこうやって
押さえて中に入らなくちゃいけない
降りる時も同じなんです私は宇宙に行っ
たら
みんなこうやってはいどうぞと
どうなるか
先に降りれば一旦
進むでしょうに
私はもうかなり凶暴な獣だと思うならば
それはまあ別に
家だけどね
獣先に
だからこの
その場合今言った件では
競争ではなくて可能理性的な順番でしょう
だからエスカレーターで降りる時でもね
下にいる人は
先に言っちゃうと大変なことられますよ
もう
だからそれが
謙虚でしょうかね
社会に怯えて生きること
その人間も結構いるでしょう
社会に参加しない
あの結構5年ごめんと言ってもう一回怯え
て控えて
生活する
またこんな人間見ますよ
言わなかったら
死霊がなかったら何もやらない
頼んだらしくしましょう
自分で考えてやらない
例えば会社が入ったら
自分の上の人はあんたこれやってください
と
これやってください
言わなかったら
言ったら真剣魔女にある
結構いるでしょう
何も言わなかったらまぁゾンビでいるん
ですねはい
呼吸はですかね
それでこれお願いします
それで人間に戻ってやってそれからまた
ゾンビに戻る
本当に今宗教人間が
それから
曖昧中途半端に生きること
まぁ
特色ですからね
そういうではないんですね結局は
だから見つける
[音楽]
たくさんありますね
というわけでじゃあその中から何か何か
選んで
適当に
組み立てて作品でどうですかね
どちらでも
極限に行かない言わないいかないでまぁ
ちょうどいいところバランスところ
取って取って取ってその
性格で自分
の性格にすると
同じ結果ですよ
はいこの間違いから
間違いの一部一部一部一部取って1個作っ
ても101番目も
面白く間違いでしょう
はいそれでいきます
それから
今言ったのはっきり言えばこのちょっと
逃げている
これではないということにこれも
謙虚として
扱いますね
ポジティブ
なんとか
間違いは分からない
これはわかりますね
自分の意見に故障しない
意見がありますでも誰かちょっとこれはで
言ったら何をあなたはもう私はこう意見だ
からみんなそんな意見に賛成しなさいよと
いう態度だったらもう大反対ですね
自分に意見がありますよあるんだけど
人の意見を素直に聞いてみる
あんたどんな
[音楽]
考えあんたどんな考えそれ理解する
Aさんがこんな考えBさんがこんな会社は
こんな考えてabcdc
は何に立ってもいいんです
そういう考え
その中で私はこの考えとかねよく
聞いて理解できる
Aさんがこういう考えあるのは
aさんにはこの理由はあるから
Bさんがこれに反対するのは
Bさんにはこれなりの
理由があるからやと
理解すること
相手に反論する自由を与える
自分の生き方に自分の考え方に自分の判断
に
人が意見持っているのならば
いわゆる違う意見持っているならばどう
する言ってくださいと
それに向かって攻撃しちゃうともう人間で
はないっての私のです
もう人間じゃない
で
あるならばどうぞという感じで自分が
生きる
新しいデータを参考してそれに
自分を
向上させる
ただ食べてテレビ見て寝るんじゃなくて
いろんな
新しい
世界のね
回転するものあれこれとか知って知って
自分の
生き方にそれは
参考してみるんですだから自分の生き方も
日々変わっていくんです
で頑固じゃないんです
調和と和語を退死しに実行する
歌っているんじゃないまぁ歌ってる人は
いくらでいますよ
歌っている人に限ってないんですね
すごい頑固なんです
よく私の経験で言えばねまぁこの
単語2つは日本語の単語だから自分で国で
はないんですで
和語と調和ってこれは日本の美とかと言っ
ていると何でこいつはあまり頑固なやつや
と
すぐ感じるんですね
聞いたんです
何が調和ですかと
何か和語ですかと
聞いたらやっぱりわかってなかったんです
例えば普通のこと方ではないんですと
付き合っていたのはかなり日本のねそれ
なりの知識人社会とかね
港平等な立場で生活しようとする
この調和とは
結構難しいんです
それには
謙虚で落ち着いて
理性がないと
和合っていうのはみんな一つの輪になって
一つで
活動することでしょうそれさせるためには
そんな
遊びじゃないよ
言っただけで喧嘩止めて
みんな
仲良くするわけないでしょうに
それから
最後のフレーズだいたい
理解しやすい実行しやすいと思いますけど
皆と
平等な立場で
生活する
自分より強いかっこよく
わけじゃなくて
社会的な上下関係あるんだけどまぁ自分
よりもあまり
レベル低い
いるわけじゃなくて生命はみんな
まぁ平等でしょうと
気持ちで生活するそういうのは
本当に謙虚の
特色なんです
健康で生きることは特徴なんですね
ですからそう思うほど簡単じゃないね
じゃあ
次に進んでいますか
まだあるんですね
必要に応じて皆に
合わせて行動する
私は一緒でも皆に合わせる人間やではなく
て
必要に応じて
この
場合みんな直せるんじゃなくて
みんな
強引に行って何か引っ張ってなくちゃいけ
ないと思うことが違う
必要に応じてリーダーシップ
俺はリーダーじゃなくてこの
場合は誰かがみんなまとめなく
ちゃらってことでまとめる
必要に応じて
他人の過ちを正す
その
必要に応じてという言葉を覚えてください
例えば私はいつだって人を過ちを正そうと
言ったらとんでもない人間なんです
付き合わない方がいいんです
あまりも頑固で
人の過ちいつでも
直してあげてくださいというのはお腹もの
の教えなんです
人間は誰だって過ちを犯す生命体でしょう
でも時々アホなことやったら困る時あるん
です
時々バカなことやったらこの場合は困り
ますよと
それが必要その時そこ治すんです
それ見たってもね我々は人々の過ちを直す
べきかと
ではないんです
放っておくべきですかとではないんです
過ちから
悪い結果が出る場合
本人に
周りに
迷惑が
起こる
可能性ある場合は直してあげる
これやめなさいよと
だって皆様はお酒飲む方々ならばこちらで
何とか日本酒
持ってきて
公園を聞く私がどんなことはないんだけど
やっぱりやらない方がいいね
だから隣とはこれは
話終わってからやりましょう
という言葉言わなくちゃいけないあんた何
で酒飲んで酒やめなさい仏教では
酒飲まないで言っているでしょうにこの
野郎と言っちゃうとこれは
謙虚でも何でもないで
和合でも昭和でも何でもないでしょう
だからそういうポイントよく理解します
必要に応じてというフレーズをね
自分の意見を他人に
言うが
強制しない
自分の意見を
救世しない
時々この
家族の中で聞こえるこれで子供たちが何か
やりたいやりたがっているんだけどまぁ
そんなことは嫌ですけどという言葉言って
止まる
お母さんそれは嫌だからやめなさいと言っ
ちゃう気をするんですね
なぜならばもう
お母さんが嫌なもんだからお母さん
好きなことをばっかしやったら人間になら
んでしょうに
意見もお母さんとしてはそんなことは
ちょっと嫌いだけどねと言って
黙っていればそれで
平和で調和が
騙されます
で
明るく生活する
謙虚な人はすごくわかるんです
で理解できなかったらこの笑い芸人のこと
舞台の上で
演奏するときの
笑い返りの生活見てください
具体から降りたらすごい
頑固でとんでもない人かもしれませんだ
けど
舞台の上でね
すごく
挨拶する時期をして
明るい顔をして
みんな笑わせているんです
その時は謙虚でいないと人は笑えません
他人の
感情的なあれそういうなどに
関わりはしない
で意味があったわけじゃなくて
感情的で起こって嫉妬してもう人のこと嫌
で
悩んでギャーギャー
喧嘩する場合は
関わらない
ただ黙って待っている
しかし部屋を倒すために
客観的な
で人々は
争っている場合はもう客観的にもこうした
方がいいんじゃないのかなと思いますこの
場合はあなたが問題解決するでしょう
客観的なアイデアを
感情には参加しません
怒り嫉妬の軋みなどには
世界の社会の問題に
飲み込まれて
悩むことはない
テレビ番組なんか狙っているんです世界の
噂ばっかし
持ってきて番組を組み立てて一通りを作っ
て
あのデータちょっと取るだけでそこから
自分で組み立てるんです
ありのままに放送しますよ
そこで聞いている人々もそれに乗って
悩んだり怒ったり
感情引き起こしたりして不死がある
それに乗らない
社会の問題に飲み込まれちゃうと
社会に問題なかった瞬間ないでしょう
[音楽]
世界に問題なかった時はないでしょうに
飲み込まれちゃって自分が悩んでいると
これは病気だけでしょう
[音楽]
問題は
知っているだけで十分です
まぁそんな感じで
そういう特色あればその人は
謙虚だと
言えます
はい
次に行きます
それから
謙虚な人の
性格
信頼できる人間ですよ
世の中で人を信頼するならば
謙虚な人を信頼できます
でも
簡単じゃない喧嘩人間になることは
前のサイド二つに
ポジティブス
肯定的な
特色
発表しましたからね
真の謙虚な人を
信頼できる
人を裏切ったり
足を引っ張ったりはしませんよ
周りがその人から
迷う
面白い現象起こるんですよ人は本当に謙虚
だったら
周りが目にこれどうこれはどうすればいい
とか聞くんです
私はこんなことで
悩んでますけどどうすればいいとかね
だから自分自身が謙虚なら
周りに人々に学ぶこと
自分からいっぱいあるんです
みんな
オートで学ぶんですそれは
なんで謙虚な人は嫌な人間にならない
でしょう
周りの人々に愛される
自分と他人の間で壁がない
これも大事なポイントです
我々はみんな壁作っているんですよ
夫婦もやっぱり壁作っているんです
兄弟はね信心はあまり
壁作らないんだけどどんどん大きくなると
性格がねじっていくとか
で壁がない人は謙虚なんです
人を支配しないが人々はその人の
導きを期待する
自分が愛と支配しない
でもあまりが
教えてくださいこれちょっと案内して
ください
と
頼む
謙虚とは人格者の性格の一つですじゃあ
結論
謙虚とは人格者なんです
だから一般日本文化的に
謙虚って
暗い控えめの人やと思っているんだけど
仏教ではそうじゃないんです
明るくて人格者なんです
はいそれでいきましょうか
覚えるポイントたくさんなりますよ
ではちょっと
天の言葉も紹介します
そろそろ今日のお話は終わります
パリ語の単語は1諏訪町に2頭に3上げて
授業を覚えている方々いるならば儒教で
前半にこの2つの単語で出てくるんです
性格的に柔らかいあなたは
3番
私は戻っていうことはちょっと
抜けたんです
意図的に抜けた
かったんです
ちょっと座長ということの意味を理解し
ましょう
手話長柔軟性があること
だから
宗教の次無動ありますけどそれも同じ意味
なんです
似ている意味でちょっと
違う
柔軟性があることを人の
教えを
素直に
聞いて
学ぶ性格
私は直訳してみると
言われやすいという意味なんです
そうすると
誤解しやすいんですね
本当は言われやすいだから
先生に
教えやすい
聞いてくれる
そこで
柔軟性あるんだからその人を学んで
自分も
変える
学ぶことは2頭にとって欠かせない条件
です
私はいる人のこと学びたくないという
気持ちがあったらさっさと
筑西に生まれ変わってくださいよ人間では
ダメです
人間の世界ではもう
学ぶ学ぶ学ぶ学ぶ学ぶ
一度学ばなくちゃいけない
私は
老人としてどう生きるべきかと学んでいる
んです
で
わがままではない
自我を張らないという意味もありますよ
この
手話長という単語の中
わがままな人には学べないでしょう
自我張る人にも学べないでしょう
そこで見当たりというのは
マンゴーをなくした
破壊したという意味です
に旗っていうのは殺しちゃったって
言うんですよ
文字通りではアラカンです
マンゴー
殲滅したのは
勘ですねしかし一般的な意味で
満を
張らないという
意味でも使います
をあるんだ漫画あるんだけど
実行させない
スイープモードにする
あなたにというのは高慢ではない
頭にではないということですこれは一般の
社会にも
適用できます一般人誰にも漫画あるんだ
けどこれ高慢にしないでくださいと
でそこを合わせると日本
語で言う謙虚なんです
はい次のサイトに行きます
これからこの説法仏教の中のお話に来ます
ね
謙虚意向に格差なんですね
だったら我々には私は謙虚な人間やって
いることはちょっと
自己紹介できませんよ
から
本当は
格差の性格なんです
漫画ある限り自我という錯覚がありますよ
自我のある人は
惨めになることがあっても
謙虚になることは難しいんです
時々我々は結構惨めであるんですねあれ
漫画あるからなんです
漫画ある限り謙虚になることは
難しい
前の
思い出してください
最大2つで説明したんだからね
ポジティブやスペクト
何でしたっけ
モレス
結構大変です
で
我々は
漫画あるんだから
結構やられちゃって
右目になることはあるんですね
右上になるということは怒りが
自分を抑えたということで
悪いことなんです
揺るがなどの境地に達しても
自覚が残っているんですやるかに乗っても
自分がいると自覚がまだあるんです
もう自我がないんです
でも自覚
のこと
自我がなくなったら
管理研究になっていますでも自分と自覚が
あるんだからその分ちょっとまだまだ
トラブル可能性あります
しかし
悟りの1と1ごとに
謙虚であることも上がります
夜かより一らいかが
謙虚です
一来かより
不原価が研究です
不限界よりアラカンかが
謙虚観察です
まぁ思いだったんだけどある最低の方の
エピソードで
お釈迦様が
あるお坊さんに
この最近の人のその人の知り合いでその人
の家に
用事があって行く予定でもあったんだから
あなたの
家に行くのそうでした方は
例えば立派なと
仏法僧に対する広げない信仰を持ってい
ます
真剣はひとかけではないんだ
それから
よく
テカリは全部
聞いていますよということで
復元化なんです
それだけじゃなくて
結構
染まり持って能力を持ってますよ
でいても
こういうこういう成長能力ありますよ
それは坊さんはそうですかと聞いてあの方
の家に行って
ずっと会話する時は
実はねあなたのことをお釈迦様がこんな風
に今あったよと
ただその人もあまり見て
誰かにその話聞かれたんですかと
だってブッダが
最近の人を褒める一番
トップの言葉で辞めちゃったんです
誰かにその話
聞かれたんでしたけど
私一人だけですあーよかった
あなたは誰にもそれバラさないでください
と
だから
他になっているのに
それは
知られないように置いておきたいんです
要するに
立派な喧嘩が足なんです
だからみんなこれ物体に認められた世界
でしょうとか言っちゃうと壁作っちゃうん
ですよ
だから一緒に
名前で呼び捨てて名前で読んで
議論したり
ディスカッションしたり教えてもらったり
することできなくなるんですだからその人
はそれ考えて
謙虚でいるんですよ
というわけで
仏道の人は
修行の一環として謙虚であることも
実践してみるんですこれでわかるでしょう
謙虚であるということは修行の一つです
これは
生まれすぎ続いてこないんです
今日から我々にも
謙虚
修行することはできます
では謙虚修行
謙虚の実践
仏性は誤解から始まるでしょう
まず
参議院ですね
産経で手話長ということを学ぶんです
いわゆる
言われやすい性格
学ぶ性格
仏法僧っていうのは師匠なんです
自分が弟子なんです
生徒なんです
だから生徒として
ちゃんと学んで学んで自分を
直していかなくちゃいけない
だから
仏道の修行は尊敬から初めて
産経も修行です
私宗教的に歌を
プレイスじゃないんです
歌ありますよもうブッダウンサラダになっ
ちゃうねとかね
そんなもんじゃないんです
インドのものすごい重要な
多少がいたんでしょうもう
ラタマンですか最近亡くなられたんだけど
随分と教えてそれでもそこまででも歌って
いたんでしょう物凄いもう
体重な曲歌って歌ってね
彼女も分断されなくなっちゃうと歌って
いるんです
[拍手]
これは
弟子になること
生徒になることということは
謙虚になることも
スタートしたんです
手話ちゃってところから
それから
誤解でしょう
誤解っていうのは項目科制ながら
頑固で守ることじゃないんです
そうすると守り辛いんです
誤解を守ることも謙虚になることやと覚え
ておけば
例えば殺生しない
生命の命取るということは何故何でこれは
と
もう私にそんな権利がないんだと
生命は平等やと
皆に生きる権利があるんだからその
生存権守ってあげる謙虚でしょう
守りやすいでしょう
殺生会はそうすると
2番目
与えられてないものを取ること
世にあるものは私のものじゃないやとです
から
仕事をして会社がくれたく医療かまぁ両親
がくれたものとか
自分の土地で探して
耕して
得たものとかそれで生活します
そんな
独裁者
王になったわけじゃないんだよと
思っちゃうと
気持ちいいでしょう
我を張って
他人の物事を奪うとか
そんなもう自分は
ちっちゃな生命で
与えられたもので整理立てますよと
というと
気持ちよくわかる2回目2行目もう戒律を
守れるます
で
他は説明する人時間かかりますからね5
回守る方々はそれでもって謙虚になること
を考えてください
だから専門用語で謙虚とは自我が
漫画がないこと
漫画で消えるんだからどんどんこれもう
剥がして剥がして剥がして行かなくちゃ
いけない
例えば鉛筆
4つぐらいたまにして追ってくださいと
折れませんね
だから1分1分もらえれば
イエスも折ったことになる
そういうことで
解説っていうのは
ただの宗教的な戒律何か守る
他と自分を
区別するために
あなたと私は違うんだよと
あなたはさっきの私は逃げませんようで
言っちゃうと
自我張っているでしょう
そういう仏教そういうの仏教返す
それで
気づきの実践というものはあるでしょう
ブッダに説かれた
奇跡の実践すると
自分人は
自我の
錯覚が
現れる
試験
仕組みを発見します
歩く瞑想で終わる瞑想を尋ね瞑想
食べる瞑想あれこれ実況中継でやると
自我が
牙を
向く
仕組み見えてくるんです
あここで時間が
それは因果法則で
身体に何か触れたから起きたんだよと
触れなかったらないでしょうに
だから自我が錯覚は幻覚だと
仕組み発見する
それで現象に対する執着が
消えたところで
誠の謙虚になります
それで
自我が
錯覚が消えるそれで研究完了
一般の方々は日常生活の道徳の一つとして
剣道で生活することを
考えてみるのは一般の瞑想したくない方々
とかねあまり
宗教は嫌いな方々とかでも仏教には
他の宗教にも興味があるとかねという方々
はまぁ
謙虚でいることでもやってみたらいかが
でしょうかと
健康で生活することは
仏教という宗教のことじゃないんでこう
いうのは生命の心理でした
どんな人間でも
謙虚であることはありがたいでしょう
仏典が物語っている
各所達の生き方を
参考にするんです
普通の
物語いっぱいあるんですよ
あの物語で
我々は自分も何となく
謙虚であった方がいいなとかね
理解するために物語はたくさんあります
それはもう時間ないんだからね
言う必要は
ないだろうと思いますけど
はい
次に行きます
それで一番に来る物語る
ブッダに対して物語はたくさんなります
じゃあ食べ物語としてもありますそれは
たくさんですけど
人々はそれは全部のありがとう怒っている
んだけど
あれは物語として
みるのは構いませんし
無駄な場合はこの
誰にも発見できなかった
悟り涅槃離脱を
発見して
ゲラスに達したと
皆に発表しないんです
これがちょっとヤバいでしょうね
私は小学者になりましたよと
発表することはね
でもそれが
発表しなかったら人の役に立たない
だから
仕方がなく発表したいんです
お釈迦様はこれすごい自慢のフレーズ
でしょうに
あの言葉見ると世の中どんな人間もこんな
無条件で言葉言わないんです
しかし
よくよく見ると
悟られる可能性ある人々がいて
道に迷って
困っている
幸福の強調探している
そこでお釈迦様があのね
私は真理を発見して
相当学者になっている
揺らがない知恵があるんだ
私が発見した真理は
神々梵天が
回る悪魔も人間誰にも
否定できません
すごい大胆な言葉でしょうそうするとあの
方々は
では教えてくださいということになるん
です
だからそれはブッダやらなくちゃいけない
ことであったんだけどそれだけです
それからブッダの管理の言葉あるでしょう
あれってかなりの
フレーズですよ
唯一の存在であるようなねだから
考えられないほどの
自慢といえばもう
客元なんですでもそれを
自分ではないんですただあり様を
発表するだけです
ですからお釈迦様のあの言葉ね漢字の言葉
見てもお釈迦様は
地盤の世界一
謙虚さがゼロの人間ではなかったんです
悟っているんだから
謙虚ということは感染しているんです
これ感じないんですね読んでも
唯我独尊というのは日本語でなんかしか
理解してない人々はこれはちょっと言い
過ぎじゃないかなっていう感想を持ってい
たんですでも我々は原文で覚えているんだ
から
合わせろそう
感じないんです
何でやり方かと思うだけです
釈尊は
ご自分のことを
第三人称で語ったんです
ですからお釈迦様は私という単語を捨てて
如来という単語を使って
第三人称
これはすごく違うんですどうしても人は
喋る場合は私は私はというんです
例えば私は流通線というのは
どこかわからんだけど何とか山です今日
手に出てください
で3年
修行しましたと
一般の人言うんだけどブッダなら
狙いは
類似線に3年
修行しながらそうなったと未来は
第3連勝
だから謙虚は完成しているんです
言葉に
語った人が
語った人が責任を結ぶ場合
発表するアイデアが世に存在しないとき
一人称使った決算ですお釈迦様もたまに一
人称使うんです
その他ではその言葉の意味にお釈迦様責任
も住んです
あれ世の中で誰もそんな意見言ってないん
です
その場合は私が解くというんです
それが
自慢ではなく
相手に
調べきたければブッダに聞けばいいんです
相手が反論したければ
ブッダにやって反論すればいいんですその
場合はお釈迦様が一人称使うんです
他専務第三人称あの膨大な経典
そういうわけで
暗い人じゃないでしょうに
救いたいたんで活動したでしょうでも
ケントです
はい次に行きます
お釈迦様の次2番目に黒な財布で損じゃな
んですね
エピソードはたくさんありますよ
[音楽]
ある程度で
調べましたけど
あまりまとめに行くたくさんなりすぎだ
からもうこういう風では
いろいろ物語エピソード
紹介
して
思ったんですね
リーダーとして
認定されたんですね
立候補しなかったんでしょう
私を選んでくださいと
私の投票してくださいとなかったんです
お釈迦様はご自分で
られるんじゃがあらかに達したら
今日からビクさんがのリーダーとして
認定します
高齢で大変ですよ
される存知の話聞いてないんです
あんたそれで大丈夫ですかとかね
ナショナルは
お釈迦様はリーダーだと教えない限りこれ
は成り立たない話なんです
知恵の第一
どうしても出家する人々に教えなくちゃ
いけないんです
で
私はブッダのところで
ブッダのに消えて処刑されたんだけど
あんた何様やと言われると
相手に修行できなくなるんです
だから出家する人にも手話長という
特色ある謙虚ということ
実践しなさいという命令でしょう
そのためにまずお釈迦様が
飛んじゃう
血の第一と
陸さんが陸さんがのリーダーです
認定したんです
でも
そんなことは知らんという感じです
すごく珍しいんです
だからお釈迦様は飛び飛びあんたねあんた
もうみんなのリーダーでしょう
自覚しなさい
言われる時はあったんです
そこでいろんないろんな
地方から
陸達が出血でしょうに人々は出家する人々
はみんな
シャーリップで損じゃが我々の思想で
大小ではなくてもう
山河の
データであるということはとても手を
合わせて尊敬しているんですがサリクソン
じゃにあったことはないんです
誰かそれを進んじゃかわからないんです
必ず
存在しますという感じで
生還するんです
触り心地損じゃが
自分の仕事はする
新しいあなたどこからどんなわけでしょう
したのかとはいこういうこういうわけそれ
であなたはこういうことを知ってますかと
かねこういうことを知ってますかとかね
いいです
全部教えてあげるんです
そこでもう
幸福様子なんです
一緒でも人の
生活
気持ち
理解能力
チェックしながら
語るんです
たまたまじゃであることは僕たち知って
いる場合もあるし
先輩のお坊さんだ
からまあ
説法しているんだじゃあ学ばなくちゃって
ことになったんです
そこで溶けてお釈迦様が
変なことするんでしょうお釈迦様も時々
すごいもしかしてもまず発表してこれから
私はこのテーマについてびくたに語ります
言ってテーマを出して
ちょっと疲れたんだから私横になりますと
仏陀がテーマだったところで説法完成する
ところまで
語れるということは
他どんな生命にもできないんです
はいわかりましたと言って
座ってその
終わるまで
語るんです
それでお釈迦様はそこら辺で
横になっているんです
お釈迦様いるんだからちょっと緊張するん
だそれはないんです
だって謙虚感性だから
説法終わったらお釈迦様立ち上がって
武器たちを実はこれは私が説法したっても
同じ
言葉として同じことになりましょうと
みんなそれその通りに覚えてなさいと言っ
て
終了して
終わっちゃうんです
これがもう大変なことなんですよ
そこで時々
仏教でなんせ何でも人々いるでしょう
違う意見持ってじゃあ
教頭の方々
かなり王様にしてかなり迫力あって議論
すると
何のことだけ行くんです
そちらに
俺は触り心地さん私だから
君たちはそんな態度ないんですただ友達と
して
友達たち何か喋っていたんですかねとかね
私は
ブッダとのね
青い事言っているんだからそれは
批判していましたよと
どういうところでしょう聞いてしっかり
議論するんです
議論して
みんな仏教徒にさせるんです
しかし
謙虚感染しているんです
議論する時でも
謙虚だから
みんな気持ちいいんです
あんた言ってる方間違っているでしょうと
そう言わない
私の話聞いちゃうと結構腹が立つでしょう
これは
ならないんです
だから人が
質問だったら
その他はどんな理由でどんな証拠に基づい
てこの意見語るんですかと教えて
ちょうだいそれを言うんですね
私はこういうところでこういうところで
これは
成り立ってないと思いますよという風に
議論するんです
だから
悪いぼっちそんじゃが自分の仕事をすごく
この
裏方でやるんでしょうに
で最近の方々が亡くなったとか色々有名な
エピソードありまして
ブッダにあって何かすごい
暗記するFACE覚えて
喜んで変えると
裏方です
あなた調子に乗っているんだけど何やと
です
上司の論文が乗らないもんがねだから
こんな大事な言葉の宝もいただいたんだ
から
そうでしょう私にも教えていただけません
かとたら
早いよ教えてあげるんです
言ったら
あなたにこの言葉の意味
ブッダに聞いたの
そんなエネルギーじゃないんだ
それだったらどうやってこれ
実行するんですかねと
ちょっと
失敗でしょうにと
ブッダ自身から意味を聞いてない
聞く必要ないだってあなたいるでしょう
それで反対いるでしょう
安定してくださいよと
はいわかりました座ってくださいと言って
説明してあげるんでこんな風に実践します
よと
もう一つ経典でこのすっごいこの
解脱のステージについてあるお坊さんと
なる
経典で
対話するんです
10個の1ステージ語れていますけどね
これ経典があったら
あのお坊さんがそなたの名前は何ですかと
お坊さんまぁ私はサリプルに言われてい
ますよと言ったら
びっくりします
偉大なるこんな
みたいな
名前
聞いただけで緊張しちゃうんだよともし
知ったならば私に一言もアイディア出ない
だろうと
だから
そういう
すごい刀がありませんが
で子供たち出家するとね
どうしても触れる存知のところ
行ってそこで済むんです
ありがとうじゃもうまぁおじいさんみたい
な感じでみんなの面倒見てあげては
わがままを聞いてあげるわとにかく
育てる
だからお釈迦様も
自分の息子も
伝説では7歳でしょうという話ですけど
計算しても
7歳じゃないと思いますけど
お釈迦様がさっさとに
出家したいと思ったところで子供がね
一通りは
王子だからあんたすごい財産持っていて
また出家したときは財産消えちゃったと
だから息子にそれ権利あるでしょうだから
あなたの再生をお店にちょうだいと
わかりましたで
読んで
この子はこの私の財産
欲しいと言ってますから
じゃあそこ
案内してくださいそれで言ってくださいと
知っているんですお釈迦様の財産というの
は遅延なんですよ
こんな土じゃないんです
そして
触れるんじゃが
寂しくさせて
自分が育ちました
ブッダの最低の時の
息子一人息子ですけど
ある
子供のお坊さんがね
神が
猿飛
にあるエピソードで
あるところで弓を
作る人
工場があったんですね
それでこのおっさん達何やっているのかと
子供を聞いたら
すごく丁寧にこれは弓を作りますよと
家庭説明してあげたんです
こんな
ぐにゃぐにゃ曲がっている企業かとして
それからそれ
細くしてそれからこうやって絞ってそれ
から
泥の中に入れておいてそれから
まっすぐになりますからそれでずっと
届いて
矢を作りましょうと
だからこんなだからこんな曲がった枝が
こんな嫌になりますよと
理解してそれで田んぼを取っていくとおじ
さんそれは何やってますか言ったらあのね
水がただ勝手に流れているでしょうだから
このおっさんたちがちゃんと綺麗にこう
やってこうやってこうやって
田んぼに均等に水が
入るように
ミスを
調教しているんだよと
根本セットとなると
それでいろいろ見るもの終わったら
すごいやって私たちもこれ見てあげた心
をちょっとしましょうと
言ったらその子ははいわかりました私は
頑張ります
このまま戻って瞑想を始まりますと
子供は知っているんだけど瞑想をしないん
だから普通は
やる気になったんです
原田
何するにはタコ足の時間でしょう
出家は高橋して終わってから瞑想する
でしょうそこまで言わないんです
はいわかりましたと
言ってその子はその所に戻って瞑想を始め
たんです
触り心地が
偉大なる方でしょう2
番目でしょうに
に行って
自分食べる分と
子供の分も両全部いただいてやはり余分に
頂いて
早く戻るんです
5CM
子供に食べさせなくちゃいかんやと
ではあの子はもうかなり瞑想進んでいるん
です
それ知らない
子供でしょうという感じで
お釈迦様が今
言って
んだよ
待っているんですね
どうですかね
一体ちょっと会話始めたんですお釈迦
様ちょっとデイと言えないでしょう
お釈迦様と会話しているそこでチェックし
ているんです
子供の心
地になっちゃったんです
納得
何でこの蜂にご飯持って
いるんですかねとかね
何々さんがねあの瞑想に修行すると書い
ちゃったんだから私はあのこの分まで高橋
して持ってきましたよとあそうじゃああの
子はお腹が空いてるでしょじゃあ行って
ご飯あげなさい
アラカンでしょうねあなたの
言ったら
どこまで
謙虚かというとね
あるいはこのちょっと
散歩していると衣がちょっと一つの
コーナーが落ちちゃって
地面に触れたんですね
衣は地面に触れるように来てはいけないん
です
それは神子供なんでしょう
どうして
ウロウロたくさんの子供達いたんだから
全然
プルモが
陥って触れてますよと
言ったら見て
合唱してありがとう
ございますこれを教えてくれて
行って
子供を治しちゃったんです
我々はそうか
関係なくやっちゃいますけどね
でと言ってもシャーリップで存在にはこの
のことを
怒っていたお坊さんたちもグループがいた
んです
この大分だっていうのは大阪の親戚です
けどね
題名だって出家してもうものすごく
活動を始めたんですね
もう大事だと褒めるんで大変だったの
か本当にすごい真面目に頑張ってますよと
か
触りぶった尊重に褒められると大分だって
その立場がかなり
上がっちゃうんですよ
そこでだいぶだとはブッダに反対してね
ブッダは暗殺して自分がブッダになりたい
と
クーデターやろうとしたところにそれバレ
ちゃって
困ったのは触り心地なんですあんた
褒めていたでしょうにと
やっぱりそののはね褒める時は褒めるん
です
そこでお釈迦様はそれして
代理だったが
分離を
やろうとしたところでやっちゃったんだ
けど
これはやってはいけないことだからね
お釈迦様あなたの
弟子たちでしょうにと
みんなそうやって来い
言ったらそれはいくらでお釈迦様はじめ
から
褒めていたんだから立場がまずいところ
ないでしょうにアラカンだからはいわかり
ましたとさあもう
調子に乗りやがっちゃって
自分のことを触り心地偉大なる
んだからほら見て私のところに来ているん
だよ
隣にいた効果ありかというお坊さんがね
ちょっと
投資で乗るなよとブッダリに成り上がって
いるのはいいんだけど
サーリプと存在はそう簡単に読める方じゃ
ないんだと
あんた何知っているのを私たちは昔から
知っている方だから
ブッダになりやがっちゃってはい
じゃあ私の代わりに続けて
説法してくださいと
ブッダの真似したんです
謙虚だからはいわかりましたありがとう
ございまして説法を始めたんです
終わり
終わるとあの努力が
真理を発見したんです
立ち上がってじゃあ
すごい
病気になっちゃって血を吐いてそれから
落ちなくなられたんだけどね
で
ある坊さんがね
作用するんじゃと
すごい腹が立って
ブッダが褒めすぎやとこの人のこと
なぜならばお釈迦様はビクたちを褒めて
ならば
褒めた箇所が多いんですね触ることするん
じゃない場合は
あまりが多いんです
ブッダのフェイバリット
こんなことよくないんだとお釈迦様に平等
に
対応しなくちゃかんではないかとだから何
とかやろうと思って
触り心地するんじゃない過ちを探している
んです
見つからないんです
気づかないところでちょっと
散歩しながら
衣を入れ替える
時
後ろに行ったら衣がパッとその人の体に
当たったんです
自分でそんなこと気にしなく
わかるなかったんだからその場合も来て
言っちゃったんですそれでこの人は一人
作るんです
火力で尊者は
自分を
殴って
衣であってもね
すいませんごめんなさい言わなくちゃいけ
ない
そんな
性格それはないんだと
頑固へと
仏陀の2番目だから
調子に乗っているんだ
とだから
解離数は犯しちゃったんだと
言ってお釈迦様に訴えるんですお釈迦様が
いくら褒めてもねあの人は
帰りそう貸してみましょうと
頑固で態度でかいやと
そんなこと
言うなよと
正しい誤りなさい
とは考えて
まぁ分かりますよお釈迦様の気持ちも様の
フェイバリだからね
気に入りだからお釈迦様の言葉も理解
できるんだけどでも
間違いを犯したことは良かったんだよ
3回も断ってお釈迦様
受けなかったんだけど
3回目から
喋れませんだからね
あなたは謝らなかったらあなたはもう
かけがえのない罪を犯したことになります
そうするとブッダにもどうすることもでき
ないんだ
から本人が怒って帰っちゃったんだけど
そこで
すぐあの
場所を離れたらもう体からできものが
ダラダラと現れちゃって
すごく苦しんで倒れちゃって死んじゃった
んです
だからまぁ
その時計から
こういう風に言われたんだけど
本当に
[音楽]
頑固
傲慢ですかと
何も言わない何も言わなくたって困ります
よと
言ったら
自分の心の宇宙を語ったんですそれすぐ
苦しいで
自分が
托鉢で出るときは
深職の
負荷食民族の人が
すごい高貴な人々が住んでいる
ところに入る場合はどんな
気持ちで入るのかと
それぐらい
自我を捨てて
謙虚で抱っこ遊びますよと
自分が生活するときはこんな
生活やと
例えで言うんですね歌だからね
若者を
二人が結婚する結婚式
そこでどうせ
インドの場合は
男もすごいおしゃれするんです
そこで結婚を結ぶ時誰かが
死んだ
青大将の
亡骸も腐っている
匂いです
泣け殻を輪っかにして
首にかけたら
お婿さんの
だからお嫁さんよりも効果のアクセスで
つけているときなんです
どれぐらい屋の若者が自分がこれ嫌がるの
かと
言語に感じるのかと
私はこの
肉体をその気持ちで
感じていますよという歌で聞いたんです
けど
すごい
感動するな感動する
経典ですよそういうことでまぁ
あるんだけどでも健康であることはどんな
あれかも
謙虚です
次に行きますか
また
全ての修行者の問題を
解決したり
個人的な
心配事が起きた時も
助けてあげたり
サクションが説法を始めて休む気になっ
たら
書籍を解いて教えを
完成することができたのはそうじゃだけ
です
ブッダの言葉が
難しくなったら
直ちに詳しい解説で皆に理解できるように
するんです
京都の方々と対話と
議論も行いますしかし
自分
個人を
批判される時は
落としないんです
あるドラマ人がね
触ることが
謙虚で
有名私知って
忍耐とかね
忍耐ですね
こんなに合う嘘でしょうと
言って後ろから行ってものすごく
力いっぱい頭殴っちゃったんです
殴った途端どんな人でも見るでしょうに
見て何であと私殴るのかいと聞くでしょう
に
それ期待していたんです
それは何のことなく
後ろも見ることもなかったんです
今のうち今のうち後ろ見て私
何か用でしょうでこの人も
後ろから行くんです
やはり
財布で損じゃが忍耐のないただ
普通の人間やと証明したかったんです
でもそれはなかったんです
それで
びっくりしちゃって
怯えちゃって
怖くない
身体から
ずっと足が出て何とことをしたんですかと
謝らなかったら大変やと思って
助けて前に行ってハリボンじゃの前に
動かして
頭下げて吸いません謝りますすいません
謝ります
何のこと
何のことですかねと
あれももう
全く気に忘れているんです何でこの人謝る
のかとこれは疑問なんです
ですからまぁそういう性格なんで最終的に
来ます
せいぜい
あらかになった
すべての教えじゃ達は
謙虚を完成したのです
格差であることを
発表しないんです
あれかに達したらその人は私は
悟っただけ
行ったことなんです
師匠であるブッダに報告するんです
今は師匠にだけまぁこういう風になりまし
たとはい
言うんだけどそれ
きり誰にも言わない
解脱に達したことを認める
ブッダの言葉によって
他人に伝わるんです
問題は何々
陸がまぁ完全に
ボールの無くして裸になりまた
言うんだから聞きたい時は何々
〇〇
[音楽]
しかしもう一つケースあるんです涅槃に
入るとき
ブッダに頼まれて
自分たちが達した出世権的な能力を
発表するが
直ちに涅槃に入るんです時々が
寿命を割ってお釈迦様に最後に挨拶して
お釈迦様ありがとうございます私はもう
入りますというとまた
色々修行したんだからね
どれぐらい能力あるのかでみんなに教えて
あげて
ちょっと自分が
悟ったことと
腎臓持っていることやら
全部デモステーションして
発表するんですしかし
すぐに入りますだからそれは最低の一般人
には
すごいお坊さんやとか売り物にすることは
できないんです
これ
紹介したいケースがありまして
社会の批判を打ち切ってお釈迦様が
女性にも出家見てみたんですね
[音楽]
お釈迦様がの
母親がねあのいわゆる
育てた母親がねお釈迦様は事実の母親とし
て
愛していたんだけど
彼女ですねリーダーになって出家したかっ
たのだからそれだけは嫌だ
お母さんに迷惑をかけたくないでしょう
だからまぁ
彼女は
息子だからね
それも
如来に対して
違反ですね
母親だからわがままでいることもどう
しようもないんです
だから困っていたんです
そこであなたは論理的な徳を出してね
女は悟れない何もかと
日本の男はないやと
だったらあなたのお母さん
断ってね
まずいでしょうと
分かりました条件付けますと
ちょっと
条件すぎちゃってそれで出家
完成なんです
しかし
ぐっと見やらか
が
お年だからね
涅槃に入る時期がありたいんです
ブッダに最後の
別れの挨拶して私はこれから日本にあり
ますよと
言ったらお釈迦様が大手に
あなたは出家させて私はもう
散々非難動きます逮捕と
だからあなたの出家は
全く無駄ではなかったと
みんなに教えてあげなさいと
言っちゃうと分かりましたと
言って自分がどんな精神的な修行でどんな
境地に達しているのかと
みんなに喋って新たになったことも喋って
いろんな人生を持っていると思う
発表してそれも見せてみんなにこんなこと
もできますよと
言って挨拶してはい帰りますと
だからそういう最高の場面でそれもお釈迦
様に頼まれて
自分が悟ったことは発表するんだけど
全ては
謙虚の
完成さなんです
はい次にありますかね
これで終わりです
どうしますか
はい
あと25分ぐらいがありますけれど
次を通る時間にいたしましょう
ちょっと時計を
10分間
休憩の後で
質疑を取る時間を取りたいと思います
よろしくお願いいたします
[音楽]
それでは
再開いたします何か
ご質問ある方そしていただきますでしょう
か
ありがとうございます
先ほどの
スライドの中に
謙虚=
各社のところなんですけど
漫画ある限り
自我という錯覚があるというのがありまし
た
私の
勉強してきた中でこの
マーっていうのは
相手と自分を比べて
相手の方が上だとか
同じくらいだとか下とかっていう風な意味
だと思ったんですけどもっと詳しく
よろしくお願いいたします
丸のことを詳しくという意味ですか
万っていうのはこの
[音楽]
自我の
錯覚っていうのはもうどうせ錯覚だから
いろんな形に見えるんですね
[音楽]
だからこのはいろんな方で見えるでしょう
そんな感じで自分の自我が
一番最初にマンという形で出てくるんです
安定なという
言葉から作ったもので
回っていうのは測る
という意味なんですね
仏教同士として
捉えて
測ってみるという意味になっているんです
そこで自分という
尺度とって
楽しみを図るんです
じゃあ
世界的に言えば
人間っていうのは
ものすごい
傲慢
傲慢でしょう
人間もまとめて
言えば奉納作品という
生き物が
奉納さというにあれができるこれができる
言葉しゃべれる
地球上にある一番優れた生命体はこの訪問
者という
サルでありますそれはないそんな人間で
あると
生物学年のための重さはピンというね
生命体だけでしょう
だからそれも
地球一周の人類の真ん中なんです
わかるんです
生命で見られないんです
あ猿田アヘビだ
とかねよく見ると
自分と同じ環境を分け合って生活してね
進化している
生命体でしょう
ライフサイトがみんな
同じでしょうに
猿はもう
遺伝子的には
97か8ぐらい同じ
電子なのに
喋れないでしょうとかね
喋れないんだからと茨城ありますかね
何でしょう
喋って何になったんですかね
さらには喋る必要はないんです
だから鳥たちは人間でも
気に着物
登れないしね猿の癖
空を飛べないし
何でけしからな生命体やと
言ったらどうそれも論理的でしょう
ですからこの人間がすごくあれやこれで
それは満々なんです
それで個人個人でそのまま持っていてねだ
から我々慈悲の瞑想それ破ってくださいと
生きて
くださいよと
これ孫を破るために言っているんです
生命として感じてください
生き物を通して自分の他人も
それから人間社会に限っちゃうともう
自分と
同等か上か下か
測ってみるんです
これでいい加減でしょう時々自分より上と
墓上やと結果出た人とある時は
自分より低いでしょう
いろんなもう
計算結果が出ます曖昧中途半端な
しっかり測ったならばデータずっと同じ
でしょうそうじゃないでしょう
ある時
なんかかっこよくて私よりちょっとなんか
立場があるみたいなと思ったらそれ上に
傲慢にはかったでしょう
また一年経って言ったら何か痩せてそれ
ほどもなくてなんだそんなものになって私
ほどないねとかねそれで低い価値を与える
んですね
だからその
自分の気分次第で
測って
測って困るの自分なんです
馬鹿っていうのはそれは分からないんです
だから勝手に困るんで自分で測ってやがっ
てそれは満ということですはい以上です
仏像の実践によって
自我の
自我を薄くなっていくことが
謙虚という考えてよろしいでしょうか
[音楽]
実践というのは
尊敬するところからも
謙虚の
修行です
もう少し時間かかりますが
ご質問ある方教えてください
はいではどうぞ
さっきの話の中で
例えばニュースとかを見て
例えばその暗い気持ちに
巻き込まれないようにしようって言うん
ですがやはり私も結構座ってそういうの
考えたところで
例えばそういうニュースに対して何だか
怒ったり
落ち込んだりなんかそういった気持ちが
やっぱり結構出てきてしまうんですねで
そういった気持ちをこう
カットするにはなんかそういったなんか
実践とかそういうのってあるんでしょうか
特にあの
テレビの
番組っていうのは全部組み立てたい
ストーリーでしょうね
[音楽]
で問題はこの
リアルタイム
というのは何となく
ニュースとして成り立たないあるいは一つ
の本当にテレビのこのアミューズメント
手段なんですよ
結局は
だから荷物番組も一つのアニメーションに
なっているんです
娯楽は妄想世界でしょう
感情の世界でしょう
だからこの
誤解で
8回やる場合はこんなことやめなさいです
[音楽]
だから私はテレビをやめて随分時間経って
ますけど最初は何かしら
情報
必要だからね
[音楽]
説法するためにね
データ取る手段としてね今はまぁネットで
情報
プログラムにいくらでもありますから
そこを見ることにしているんです
最近は宇宙のこととまた
世界のことを何か誰かさんのユダヤ人
ありそうですけど
物の見事に宗教の歴史とかするんですね
ああいうものでまぁ情報
データを取るんです
だからリアルタイムニュースというのは
流れると
見ている人にとってもそんなに面白くない
んです
すごい
素直なんです
我々は激しい
切り替えになるなっているんですね
そういうことだからじゃあどう見るべきか
というとやっぱりこう見てるそうですかね
世の中の人々はね貪瞋痴で餅で傲慢で
我が輩は偉大なりやという錯覚で生きて
いるんだからこんなこともならこんなこと
になるこんなことになる
酷い目に舞う
それでも自我を
故障するとかね
ロシアにしたってももう
怒ら結果になってないんだけど自我だけ
貼って苦笑するでしょうに
だからこの
そういうこの
ジェラルアンダスター
という人類を一般的に
離れて立場から理解するという
感じで見た方が
飲み込まれないと思います
はいでは
ちょうど
終了の時間になりましたのでこれで終了し
たいと思います
はいでは今日の流れですねあの
まぁ直接ブッダの言葉の説法よりは
仏教に一つの概念まとめて
仏教のそれでもいつでも仏教の本当の
真髄を私は語ってきましたけど
謙虚という日本語の言葉は
借りて
仏教の先生を
語りました
ですから今日のお布施というかねあの
講演会
実践できたのはこの
前がマジックさんのお店で
再び
説法完了しましたから
この方々と
関係のある方々
それから
ブッダの世界に
ほんのちょっとの時間皆様にも一緒に生活
することができましたし
皆様はもしかすると私の話で乗って
同じ思考パターンだと思いますよそうする
とある程度のなんか模擬的な瞑想にもなり
ます
とはだから
説法を聞いて悟りに達する人よりますから
ね夜から
そういうことで皆様も
大変功徳を
吸いましたので
皆様にも心の
安らぎが私られますよね悩み苦しみがなく
てありますように
煩悩がなくなりますように知恵が現れます
ように
解脱することはできますようにします
[音楽]
苦しんで
悩む生命が苦しみになる
恐れて悩む生命がそれなく
悲しんで悩む生命が
悲しみなく一切の生命があるのであります
ように
はいありがとうございます
[拍手]